okay so we are gonna round it out
uh
so that's a challenge after this week
um ups and downs for everyone I'm going
to talk a little bit about the midterms
but I want to uh to end things with with
hope
tonight and a little bit of the energy
that I think we need
so it's now clear that the 2022 midterm
elections did not turn out the way uh
the American right thought they would
including myself
but they didn't reveal much that we did
not already know
we continue to see a deepening divide
throughout our nation
the views of roughly half the population
of America are increasingly suppressed
and delegitimized by most major
institutions and media Outlets this
difference in opinion is not a mere
matter of policy preferences Americans
are divided about what men and women the
family citizenship and nation states are
and ought to be as well as when human
life begins and ends
that's just the reality of the situation
we find ourselves in a few want to admit
the reality of that situation which is
painful
but Americans are now divided over the
building blocks and purpose of human
civilization
many do not consider what underlies all
the factionalism we see amidst the noise
but that doesn't change the sordid
reality
nearly every major institution in
America be they commercial cultural
political or educational is in the grip
of a totalizing ethical system of
thought a way of life that is
fundamentally at odds with our own
in 2020 they all bowed down to it
publicly accelerating change for the
worse
and although a more robust federalism
combined with what I am here to suggest
to you tonight may buy us time there's
no possibility in my opinion of
ultimately reconciling this fundamental
opposition unless one side or the other
wins
now in a very different America the
American rights set out to conserve
American institutions in an American way
of life through political action and
advocacy
uh you know the culture war was always
real but for good or ill for the most
part it was thought to be fought with an
explicitly political spaces via
explicitly political means business and
the economy were considered neutral
spaces subjects disciplined from
shareholders and market demand
today however uh the the the simple fact
the brutal reality of the matter is that
few Elite professions or corporations
allow their members to safely dissent
from woke Dogma everyone knows that they
risk their job and career if they do so
publicly
uh the woke agenda in other words has
been grafted into most major
corporations and since culture is made
in large part by corporations mainstream
media and culture have largely turned
into tools to support one side of the
Divide
in short the American cultural and
political landscape has been bulldozed
and fundamentally reshaped over the last
century
a one-party oligarchy tied to the
radical ideology of identity politics
rigidly controls our major institutions
as populous resistance struggles but
Rises to meet it
digital technology continues to reshape
human perception human behavior and the
Very structure of human communities and
institutions causing an escalating War
over its control
and the nature of this conflict is
purposely obscured by many of its
participants and the rest of our
leadership class is often too blind or
too frightened to describe it
it's it's not only hard to come to grips
with the depth of our division it's
difficult for those formed in a very
different and healthier America to see
it
the gap between the experience of older
and younger generations of Americans has
created a dangerously dangerously
disparate visions of the reality in
which we're all operating
but I think for everyone here and
increasingly for everyone else people on
both sides of the deepening divide are
aware that what's at stake
is what the American way of life is and
ought to be in the 21st century
after this week it's a good time to
remind ourselves of this elections well
they're important
essential are not ultimately going to
save us
and I don't mean to disparage either man
nor the vital importance of the
statesmanship which we are now
desperately in need of
but on their own neither Donald Trump
nor Ron DeSantis are going to save you
either
we citizens
dedicated to truth goodness and Beauty
to the best of what western civilization
in America was and must now be rebi
shaped to become again we citizens must
act
and and this action must involve more
than voting and giving money to
whichever politician we think will fight
to win as some of you may have noticed
in your lives and you may have noticed
this week this strategy is sadly not
always an effective one
but as so many people are asking and as
I suppose a lot of us are here together
this week to discuss
what is to be done
and I would submit that the answer lies
in a model provided by the college on
the grounds of which we are gathered
here tonight
straightforward answer is that we will
not retake America and its co-opted
institutions unless we band together to
form and reform new ones
when it comes to saving higher education
the only strategy that ultimately worked
over the last two decades was the one
that Hillsdale College shows
the others had their upsides that worked
in some ways
But ultimately utterly rejecting the
totalizing system of the rest of
Academia and focusing on forming a new
one is what worked
consider that two decades ago and I
remember this uh it was laughable to
many that an institution outside the
mainstream could do what Hillsdale
College has accomplished during that
period of time
many would have scoffed at the idea that
an institution of Higher Learning could
reject the standards principles best
practices and purposes of the rest of
higher education on the basis of its own
standards principles and purposes
I've heard many sentiments like this
over the years when it came to reforming
educational institutions something like
you know it's not just realistic uh it's
just not realistic it's difficult it's
an uphill battle Elite schools are hard
to beat they've credentialed American
leaders for centuries and besides it'll
take a long time
but during that time Hillsdale and I can
say this because I'm not on the payroll
here uh has instead become one of the
greatest examples we have in America
of a successful new Elite Institution
Elite institutions yes yes
look Elite institutions set the
benchmarks for the rest of society they
curate and credential people and ideas
that curate and credential people and
ideas and by curating and credentialing
ideas students and teachers for a new
generation of leaders Hillsdale has
become the elite institution it is for
all of red State America
why because the college boldly planted
the flag
talented and purpose-driven people have
rallied around it because the college
has a strong understanding of its
Mission it has been able to wield
considerable influence fostering true
education throughout the nation
I submit to you tonight this is the same
model we need to apply to the economy
and commerce and media and culture this
is why I moved from California to Texas
why would anyone do that
um almost two years ago to start new
founding
so I come bearing uh bring good news
from the front lines along with a catch
the good news is that
a momentous cultural commercial shift is
now underway across this country that I
believe will become the most significant
change in American living memory
but only if talented people with the
right resources continue to work
together to Foster it whether or not we
succeed or fail and we must not fail
the geographic digital and financial
movement of millions of people and
billions of dollars out from under the
control of woke States woke digital
technology and woke corporations and
capital has already begun
and it's now the duty of all those who
wish to stop the decline of our nation
to join it
and you know I don't know what that
sounds like to you but I'm telling you
tonight I know what I'm talking about is
happening because I live and see it
every day
in some ways all of us do
consider Americans have already begun to
act
everyone knows that domestic migration
from Blue states to Red States has
rapidly accelerated over the last two
years but no one is allowed to say in
public why exactly this is so
the answer is not merely lower taxes
it's the Wall Street Journal sometimes
tells me
nor was it a temporary move to avoid
Contracting covid-19 as many on the left
have pretended
the truth is that while all the causal
factors of the last decade of migration
from Blue states to Red has remain in
place the last few years more people
than ever have been moving because of
the tyrannical actions blue States took
in reaction to the virus and the
increase of crime and politically
motivated violence such as the 2020
riots and the unwillingness of blue
states to protect their own citizens
it's a general sense in America that
things are falling apart and will likely
get worse in short people are moving to
seek a better way of life in a much
deeper sense than the phrase is usually
bandied about
now there's there's four major parts if
you look at good social science or peace
what you can from the ruins of social
science around which human happiness
typically revolves religious observance
healthy family life meaningful work and
Community engagement
now in blue one-party counties in blue
one-party States
satisfaction in each of these areas is
increasingly difficult for anyone
dissenting from the cultural revolution
to attain
harsh truth is that it makes sense for
many of those who live in such areas to
move to red or purple states to seek a
better way of life and this is exactly
what is happening all across this
country
and this should give you hope
because this is what will enable a new
commercial cultural movement that can
save America
in America the frontier is always with
us
yes we have been told that people have
been leaving New York and California for
Florida and Texas for economic reasons
for decades but in the last few years
people have begun to purposely resettle
in areas where they can live with those
of like-mind on fundamental issues
Florida and Texas are becoming more and
not less strident politically in both
States the clear results of the 2022
midterms proves without a doubt that the
Republican party is now far stronger
there than it has been in the recent
past
again I want to emphasize this point
take something good out of this week
despite all the worries about domestic
migration turning them blue and hundreds
of millions of dollars spent fruitlessly
by the left Texas and Florida just
became markedly redder red States
this trend is going to continue
as the differences between the way of
life on offer in red and blue States
becomes darker Florida under Governor
Ron DeSantis is the model of the future
for red States Justice Gavin newsom's
California is the model for the Blues
what I call the Red State mindset is the
realization that states can determine
their own destiny for instance if Red
State Republicans had a clearer vision
of what education should be and truly
wanted to stop these institutions who
are teaching the very things that are
destroying our country
they would do something about it
don't tell me how woke our state schools
are are
change out their boards and Leadership
and threaten their funding fight to win
if and when they do so good things will
happen
and we see this we see something moving
in that direction that's the good news
the boulder Red State policies laws and
actions the Republican base is
increasingly demanding make such actions
more likely and as they do so it's less
and less likely that those who disagree
will relocate there
okay
that's my take on a political scene
let's switch to the topic of the evening
the same forces driving Geographic
migration apply with even more Force to
the one-party controlled workplace
Marketplace and digital world we all now
live within
here too some have already started
moving in a promising Direction
the quietly right-leaning or just plain
non-woke dissenters and Elite ranks
suffering under this rolling cultural
revolution Are Not Alone
there are Cutting Edge leaders in
American Business who have begun to
stand up and speak out and some of them
put to shame many of those in similar
positions who call themselves
Republicans
take a few examples important to
highlight these examples good things
happening
the wealthiest man in the world Elon
Musk recently declared quote unless it
is stopped the woke mind virus will
destroy civilization and Humanity will
never reach Mars
and you call me a radical
his high profile effort to buy Twitter
for the sake of allowing dissent on the
platform I think could be adequately
described as an act of statesmanship for
the 21st century
musk has called ESG you know the
socially conscious investing acronym
used by woke Capital to dictate the
politics of business entities quote an
outrageous scam
his position Echoes the long-standing
criticism of modern America made by
Peter Thiel who's one of the most
interesting entrepreneurs and investors
in America that we are losing our
ability to innovate
now teal recently set forth what he
called I mean I could wish some
Congressional Republicans did this teal
recently set forth what he called an
enemies list denigrating some of the
largest figures in American Finance and
all those beholden to woke Capital who
stand in opposition to cryptocurrency he
labeled ESG the enemy of Bitcoin and
perhaps the most belligerent public
statement he's ever made
he called ESG
and all that surrounds it a hate Factory
equivalent to the Communist Chinese
party
and he urged the Revolutionary youth
movement dedicated to crypto to rise and
take over the world